we have a serious health crisis before
we get to the solutions let's start with
Chris Rock out of all people yes Chris
Rock and will with our special guest
let's go ahead no good so good crazy
extra-strength the lead my dude good
like 3000 milligrams yeah 3,000
milligrams Children's Tylenol welcome to
the D show for another exciting episode
no stranger to the Dean show chief
former chief chief nutritionists for dr.
Mercola
that's yeah illness that Jim Marlow how
you doing I'm doing great Eddie how are
you I'm good thank God I'm happy to have
you again in the Dino studio how's
everything how's your health thank you
thank you for inviting me back on the
Dean show and my health is better than
ever how was your health health feeling
good we just coming out of Ramadan we
were fasting and I'm feeling really good
thank God it's good glad to hear that so
we want to pick your brain we want to
get some more some more data from you
and there's a very powerful documentary
and I want to ask you about that you
usually recommend you recommend a lot
you recommended for me to watch it I
watched it and I also recommend it to
other people why is it that you think
that people should watch this
documentary it's the first part of a
docu-series it's called the truth about
cancer
global quest mm-hmm can you talk to us a
little bit about that because you
recommended that to me and it was a real
eye-opener right and you recommend it to
a lot of people so maybe we can courage
more people to watch it but why is it
what is what's so special about this
documentary
well this documentary especially the
first part of the truth about cancer
that is produced by ty Bollinger and his
his people it offers people some very
valuable truth about what the medical
establishment has to offer in regard to
the treatment of various types of
cancers that's beyond what most people
are familiar with in fact what dominates
in the mainstream about the treatments
for cancer is it's a big part of the
conventional medicine business model and
it's important to understand that
conventional medicine is first and
foremost it's it's built on a business
model and so if you're if you're
interested in going beyond the medical
establishment propaganda about what they
have to offer the truth about cancer
series especially the first episode will
give people a different perspective
about the history and the the value or
most of the time the lack of value in
taking conventional treatments such as
the poisons that are euphemistically
known as chemotherapy and radiation
treatments and other conventional
practices and so it's it's always best
to take the initiative to educate
yourself beyond just what is mainstream
what's in mainstream what dominates in
the mainstream media is what is serving
entrenched business interest it's
important to be awake to that and so
when you're when you have very important
decisions to make doesn't it make sense
that the better informed you are the
more likely you are to make the wisest
decision for yourself so that's what I
have to say I like how the you have a
lot of scientists on there you have
researchers you have doctors PhDs you
have some some very intellectual people
on there's people who kind of think out
the box also and I like how it goes into
the history it goes into the history of
allopathic medicine he gives a synopsis
in the beginning talking about you know
how over a hundred years ago how it was
all established so you get a historical
look at it and many of the funders
behind the the AMA is really deep and
profound yeah yes it attempts to answer
a very important question and that is
why are things the way they are why why
is it that the conventional medical
establishment this is is so oriented
toward drugs and the propaganda about
that it's been oh this is the best that
medical science has to offer and you
know this is it's you know it's it's
evidence-based medicine I'd like to see
some evidence-based medicine in regard
to people taking four or more
prescription drugs there is there is no
science supporting that that's safe you
know most of this most of what is
offered in regard to drug treatments
it's based on just taking that drug
there's a little bit of what you could
call science having to do with two drugs
a little bit even less with three drugs
but there's virtually no science
supporting that it's safer effective to
peep for people to take four or more
drugs you know commonly known as
polypharmacy I've known people over the
years in my own family you know senior
citizens that are on 15 different
prescriptions 15
yeah it's 20 that's not uncommon out no
it's it's it's not and where's the
science supporting that that's safe and
effective but is it problem but if the
argument comes in where now this is
helping to prolong their lives this is
something that is yeah it's helping to
prolong their lives maybe but it's
certainly not helping to improve the
quality of their lives because I've I've
I've have I have quite a bit of life
experience but family friends and and
people that I've worked with over the
years especially at the optimal wellness
center when because of the popularity of
doctor McCullough's website we attracted
a lot of seriously health challenged
people from all over the country and so
when it seems like the more drugs that
people are taking the lower the quality
of their life yeah yeah that's there may
be some exceptions to that but I can't
it's kind of like doctor would you turn
me out also to dr. Kelly Brogan she says
the same thing that most cities drugs if
not a great number of them they come at
a cost
yes so your healing one thing or not
even healing I mean you're are you
because many people think that okay if
you take this drug that it's actually
making the the problem the root problem
go away but is that the truth no no no
there is no drug that's been developed
that ultimately addresses the cause of a
health problem with the possible
exception of insulin for type one
insulin-dependent diabetic but drugs
were not designed to to cure they were
designed to treat the symptoms I'm
noticing you're saying drug now
there are difference between medicine or
drug well let the terms medicine is a
euphemism for synthetic chemicals that
can be patented the drugs
yeah drug cuz I like to think that
medicine is has a healing effect that's
what you what you'd find and you know
many of the natural herbs and well there
was remedies yes well there was a there
was a great pit a bit of wisdom more
than a bit of wisdom a profound
statement of wisdom from the ancient
Greek physician 2,500 years ago
Hippocrates the relevance of Hippocrates
is to this day upon graduation from
medical school the graduates take what
is called the Hippocratic oath
well the Hippocratic oath is primarily
about first do no harm
well Hippocrates also made a profound
statement that's of timeless value in
his day he said let your food be your
medicine and let your medicine be your
food so that was true then it's true now
but foods cannot be patented and the
driving force behind the conventional
allopathic medical industry as it was
actually created by not a scientist not
a doctor but by john d rockefeller and
his people about a hundred years or so
ago the driving force of that of that
industry is to come up with unique
chemical compounds that can be patented
you cannot patent a natural substance
you cannot patent an herb you cannot
patent a vitamin or mineral
you can only patent unique chemical
compounds these unique chemical
compounds that are then marketed to the
to the public as as medicines as you
know prescription drugs they're totally
foreign to the human body but
they are promoted by the mainstream
medical establishment which is which has
Authority status with the public they're
promoted as science-based evidence-based
medicine and this is the best way to
help people really really it's the best
way to help people to have them take
foreign chemicals into their body that
may be effective in in inhibiting or
stimulating some aspect of a person's
biology to reduce a symptom but because
they're totally foreign chemicals to the
human body they always come along come
along with what are commonly thought of
as or commonly referred to as side
effects but I think that's that's a
inaccurate way to think of it they're
not side effects when you get when you
get bad reactions to taking a foreign
chemical into your body
their direct effects from taking the
foreign chemical into your body they may
not be be they're not the the intended
effect but they're a direct effect of
taking a foreign chemical into your body
and there's there's that's always a
precarious thing to do now there can be
a place for taking prescription drugs
these foreign chemicals - for the
management of symptoms and in the in the
short-run but as you mentioned Kelly
Brogan dr. Kelly Brogan who's a who's an
MD she specializes in holistic
nutritional approaches to helping people
overcome so-called psychiatric disorders
mental disorders emotional disorders and
so she helps her patients with
depression anxiety bipolar disorder she
helps them actually rebalance themselves
and actually helps to get them off of
whatever whatever drugs they may be on
and and she basically teaches them how
to eat healthier and live healthier so
they can be healthier and free of
depression and anxiety another
I mentioned this on a previous Dean show
that the the way we approached health
problems at the optimal wellness center
was rather than treating the symptoms of
disease or dysfunction you know rather
than focusing on the person's specific
medical diagnosis we had a had a team
approach a very holistic approach to
basically teaching people how to eat
healthier and live healthier so they can
be healthier and I've mentioned this
before that what we really did for
people was we taught them that really
the best way to overcome what you could
call the darkness of disease or
dysfunction is to turn up the light of
your inner health build your health so
that that's the solution now so if
you're always has been that's the
solution so honor your body by putting
the right foods in your body putting the
right real food so right okay I'm
sitting with the gastroenterologist yeah
and we're having a talk and I'm talking
to him about this really simple concept
about just going back to eating real
food right as you brilliantly
brilliantly put it that you know real
food comes with a list of ingredients
and real ingredients not a list of
ingredients that you know are toxic
chemicals may be put in there for a
longer shelf life and and whatnot and he
was talking about that well what's wrong
with potato chips they come from a
potato I wish you were there was this
thing it was a real short conversation
because then we got split apart but then
he said okay ice cream it comes from
dairy what's wrong with the ice cream
well how would you have dressed that so
potato chips go with those - potato
chips and it for the average and this is
a doctor so now he's saying something
that logically to him probably makes
sense to a lot of people okay potato
chips come from a potato yeah potatoes
real food but now you've got the potato
chip and then ice cream is coming from
dairy that comes from the cow what's
wrong with ice cream
yeah well
the potato to make potato chips it goes
through a lot of processing and to just
keep it simple the nutritional value of
the of what's in the potato in the
process of making it a potato chip is
seriously damaged and it's adulterated
you're you're actually subtracting
nutritional value from the potato as
you're processing it to make potato
chips and then you're actually
adulterating it by adding things to it
like msg very likely or some type of
preservative chemical preservative that
is only going to be another burden to
the body's toxic assault from from
living in the modern world
same thing would ice cream you know yeah
when when when the cream was fresh raw
cream if it was from a healthy animal
out that's that's real food that's real
nutrition but when you take the ice
cream and then you you adulterate it but
you know adding sugar to it and
artificial or even so-called natural
flavorings natural flavorings are often
an industry processed food industry cold
word for msg for people that i don't
know what is what at what is actually
msg what is that ma it stands for
monosodium glutamate and it's highly
prized by the commercial processed food
industry because it's a taste but
exciter it stimulates the taste buds so
it can make poor quality food taste
better and that's what that's what is
being used in the in the commercial
processed food industry they're not
using high quality food they're using
they're using very low quality poor
quality food they don't care about the
quality of food because they know that
their food chemists can make anything
taste good by using chemical additives
that are often listed as natural flavors
on processed foods like msg msg msg not
only excites the tastebuds a lot of
people may know that but i think very
few people
understand that msg also has addictive
qualities to it so when someone opens up
that bag of potato chips that has salt
but also it has old natural flavoring on
it now not always but it could it could
be that that natural flavoring is
actually msg and so when someone opens
up that bag of potato chips and they
start eating it they have one and then
they have they want another one and
another one and another one they don't
they don't
the average American consumer doesn't
begin to understand how their eating
behavior has been and continues to be
manipulated through chemistry that
behavior of just having one potato chip
after another after another until the
whole bag of goo is gone that eating
behavior has been chemically imparted
into the food so I want to restate
something I said on my very first
appearance of the Dean show several
years ago now and this is always
something to keep in mind
it's my simplest and most basic teaching
on nutrition and it's always relevant
and that is if you want to be real
healthy then eat real food and real food
is simple food that does not come with a
label with a list of ingredients the
more labels you're reading the more
you're actually making to put it kindly
less than the best choices but you know
more labels you're reading you're going
down the wrong path yeah so you know all
the best most wholesome nourishing real
food it doesn't come with a label with a
list of ingredients I'm talking about
fresh meats especially from properly
raised healthy animals you know the
Halal meats and and also eggs and and
dairy products from healthy animals and
also fresh whole vegetable and fruit
nutrition I would encourage everybody
wherever they are wherever they are
listening to take advantage of the
farmers markets in your area
the the more the more fresh
locally-grown food you eat the the
better that is going to be for your
health the fresher your food the better
and ideally it'd be great if it's
organically grown certified organic but
if it's not you talk to the talk to the
people at the farm stand talk to the
farmer if he if he's there and asked him
about their growing methods there's a
lot of farmers who use organic practices
but they're not certified organic
because the USDA Organic certification
like the government tends to do with
everything has become an increasingly
bureaucratic and expensive process and I
know some I know some farmers who are
their third through using even beyond
organic farming practices but they're
not certified organic because they just
don't want to they don't want to go
along with you know the the government
bureaucratic procedure and and there are
some other certifications that are
worthwhile like certified naturally
grown certified naturally grown is kind
of more of a grass grassroots level
mostly run by farmers and and and people
who are working without government
involvement so what I've seen the
pattern here is like you you make these
adjustments and you start eating real
food these lifestyle shifts and changes
the quality of life gets better and you
start living better you talk about and
about the brain fog energy levels all of
these things that help for a better
quality of life and actually dr. Kelly
Brogan and others you mentioned another
doctor it was dr. Weinstein was it or
some dr. Brownson Brownstein Brownstein
many of them just like her who testify
that they were getting to a point
falling into despair almost because they
felt like they weren't helping people
they weren't really solving the people's
problems but when they started to help
people in this way with lifestyle
changes adjustments checking how people
are sleeping what they're eating quality
of life started to really get better
and they had to go out of the box
because you know conventional medicine
doesn't teach these things so they're
restricted to just the drugs a a simple
way to put that is dr. dr. David
Brownstein dr. Kelly Brogan dr. Jonathan
Wright dr. Mercola when when he was
doing his good doctoring when he was
still seeing patients a long time ago
what what they were doing was ultimately
was they were working with a person's
biology rather than manipulating it with
with foreign chemicals that can be
patented you know that that has been and
continues to be the driving force of the
conventional medical establishment it
certainly is the driving force for the
pharmaceutical industry to to come up
with unique chemical compounds that can
be patented because once you have a
patent on something you can make a lot
more money than something that you can't
get a patent on like you can't patent
you can't patent natural vitamins and
minerals and amino acids and essential
fatty acids no natural substance can be
patented so what do you know about these
stem cells therapy do you know anything
about that
well no I don't I don't know much about
that Eddie but I do know that our body
naturally produces its own stem cells
that are involved that our body draws
upon when we have some type of injury
and our body uses these stem cells to
help repair tissue to help regenerate
any type of damage including you know
stem cells are used by by our body on a
day to day basis just for normal just
ongoing maintenance of the human body
you know part of the dynamic of our
biology is there are cells old cells
being kind of slough off every day you
know old cells are being replaced with
newer cells on an ongoing basis this is
you know certainly true with our red
blood cells your body's making new red
blood cells every day making new white
blood cells every day certain cells in
our body like our skin cells are
epithelial cells that line the interior
of our body but also the exterior body
you know they are being replaced every
few days for instance just a simple
example that everybody may relate to is
that if you accidentally bite your
tongue or bike the inside of your cheek
and sure it sits it hurts a lot but if
you're if you're if you're healthy and
well nourished enough that will
completely heal with what some people
like the last time I accidentally bit my
tongue it was completely healed within a
few hours now you know someone someone
else it may take a little bit longer but
it heals very very rapid the rapidly the
body does have a god-given innate
intelligence and capability to know how
to heal to know how to be healthy the
direction of our life force energy is
always toward healing and health if you
cut yourself it heals you don't even
have to think about it it could help if
you actually gave some conscious
attention to it certainly wouldn't hurt
but you don't have to we do have this
god-given innate intelligence and
capability to know how to be healthy our
body wants to be healthy the body's
always trying to be healthy but the
health is not met has not realized
magically we need to get our nutrition
and the other fundamentals of self care
of life right enough for instance
there's no substitute for a good night's
sleep and if you're if you're off
balance if you're not feeling very well
if if you're tired if you're if you're
just not not feeling right then the
earlier you can get to bed before
midnight the better that will be for
helping your body to rebalance the sleep
issue is not just a quantity issue how
much you sleep it's also a quality issue
and the quality issue has a lot to do
with when you go to sleep there's an old
natura Pathak understanding goes back at
least a hundred years possibly longer
than that but it goes like this every
hour of sleep before midnight is worth
at least two hours of sleep after
midnight and I try to bring this to life
for people in a practical
way by you know asking them just from
your own life experience you know have
you ever gone to bed you know say it 1
o'clock in the morning and then slept 8
hours and gotten up that night almost
everybody will say yeah yeah I've had
that experience you know stay up late go
to bed at 1 get up at 9:00 okay no
that's 8 hours of sleep
does that feel the same as going to bed
at say 10 o'clock and getting up at 6
and without exception everybody says
going to bed at 10 and getting up at 6
feels better
is that true true for me it's true for
everybody that's just one example of
what I'm saying here about the earlier
you go to bed before midnight the the
better that is for supporting your
body's ability to repair regenerate you
know heal rebalance restore and ricchan
function so if someone is off balance
and their body is in need of some
serious repaired regeneration healing
work I've recommended to people you know
go to bed ideally no later than like
7:30
you know the earlier the earlier you can
go to bed before midnight that's
practical for your lifestyle the better
it is for supporting your body's ability
to heal but there is no substitute for a
good night's sleep and a good night's
sleep is largely determined by when you
go to bed as well as you know sleeping a
sufficient quantity of time so we're
talking about lifestyle changes I also
had another person who's a pioneer out
there trying to educate people a
holistic doctor dr. Syed Medina she
links a lot of the ailments you know
with this bad food and then it triggers
inflammation in the body and then the
inflammation from there you start having
many of these chronic issues now how do
you go ahead so we're talking about
drugs these drugs they manage some
symptoms but they come at a cost and you
could be taking one drug that's not
actually getting to the root of the
problem we're trying to get to the root
of the problem by adjusting your
lifestyle cutting out certain toxic
foods
incorporating good foods yeah now how do
you determine from there Jim we're okay
like for instance I just had we just had
a tragic situation with my father who
got hit by a van
he wasn't in the van he was walking got
hit by the van so now ambulance comes
now that's a trauma situation then they
take the cat scans make sure you know
he's not bleeding from the head and all
this so how do you determine okay that's
in in this situation versus now for the
where do you determine you know where
it's effective where it's not so
effective the urging welcome I see her
um the the conventional medical steps
when is at their best and urgent care
immediate care like this situation with
my father yeah that's where they
functional obsession i'ma trauma trauma
that's a trauma situation the more the
more someone the more serious someone's
injury you know the more they can be
helped by the conventional medical
establishment ninety percent of of
medical treatment in the country though
is for chronic problems you know not not
acute problems not not accidents you
know this give or take a few percentage
points on that number but the vast
majority of medical care that people
seek out is not for acute problems it's
for chronic problems that are ultimately
related to people not nourishing
themselves properly too much stress in
their lives not getting enough sleep not
getting their self-care like they need
to get it in order to realize a you know
a good level of health so in regard to
your father unfortunately being injured
like this you know that's going to be a
big stress on his biology it has been a
big stress on his biology and the more
stress on our biology the more important
nutrition is to support the body's
ability to heal to repair to rebalance
and so the better your father's
nutrition the the better his recovery
will be Eddie but there certainly I
certainly appreciate that there is a
place for your father right now if
for medical treatment and and hopefully
there they're giving him the very best
care that they're capable of giving him
mm-hmm today I would like to add one
other thing in regard to drugs never
addressing the cause of health problems
with the possible exception of insulin
for a insulin-dependent diabetic and
that's the issue with antibiotics now
someone may say well antibiotics are all
we are dressing the claws because
they're killing germs yes they are but
we have an immune system and our immune
system if it's functioning properly
because we're getting our nutrition good
and we're getting the rest of our
self-care practices well enough if you
have if you have a healthy immune system
that is your best defense against
infections and so when someone takes an
antibiotic for infection I can
understand that yet there can it can
seem like well that's the best thing to
do in the short run and unfortunately I
think there's a lot of people who
actually are in a their health is is is
is such that they actually they need
that type of treatment because they they
don't have a healthy immune system but
when you are taking antibiotics because
your immune system was too weak to take
care of some type of germ you got
exposed to the antibiotics
they don't strengthen your immune system
in fact antibiotics can further weaken
your immune system and actually set you
up for recurrent infections which we had
a lot of this of people at the optimal
wellness center often he had history of
antibiotic ongoing antibiotic usage for
recurrent infections sinus infections
respiratory infections bladder infection
and it was an ongoing thing they were
like on a treadmill of meeting
antibiotics on an ongoing basis because
they were not actually strengthening
their immune system and ultimately they
weren't they weren't addressing the
cause of why they developed the
infection in the first place their
immune system was compromised yeah and
so we do have a god-given innate
intelligence and capability to be
healthy but we need to take care of
ourselves probably you need to to to
honor your body with the best quality
food that is available to you and be
attentive to the other fundamentals of
self-care you know which are number one
actually is breathing I personally don't
miss a day of breathing exercise number
two the quality and quantity of water
you're drinking of course that's a
fundamental influence and everybody's
health because you are our body is
mostly water and then of course food we
spend most of our time talking about
food but that's eating real food
avoiding fake food yeah that's right but
you know food is actually of 3rd
importance you know if you had to like
like you know during Ramadan especially
if you had to you could go long periods
of time without eating you know go weeks
without food if you if you wanted to it
might not be a very pleasant experience
but the human body can go weeks without
food we can go days without water how
long can we go without breathing if
you're really good at holding your
breath you know
maybe a little more than a few minutes
but most people you know can't even hold
their breath for a minute but any any
type of breathing exercise you know that
you know to do that helps you to feel
good while you're doing it prioritize
putting time into that every day you
can't improve the quality of your breath
if you give some focused attention to
doing conscious breathing exercise but
the other fundamentals of health that I
want to mention after breathing water
food
our sunlight fresh air exercise activity
movement all of the above and sleep okay
now what I mean by fresh air I mean
getting outside and having having a
relationship you know what with with you
know the God created nature you know
it's like everybody getting out and H
everybody feels better outside on a nice
day than they do indoors yeah I think I
don't think that's an overstatement I
there may be some exceptions to the
hours some people actually feel better
indoors but on a nice day you know
people naturally are attracted outside
and so what I mean by fresh air is I
mean having having appreciation for
being for being out in nature you know
getting fresh air you know taking in you
know the the God created wonders of
nature you know a beautiful sky and you
know you know all the different you know
being out in the woods or in a forest or
along the lakeshore or along the ocean
shore that's that's I do believe that's
all nourishment for for for for us in
some very very important ways but also
the very simple practice of grounding
yourself which is simply walking bare
feet on the earth especially along the
lakeshore and ocean shore I saw dr.
Mercola interview a very successful
holistic minded nutritionally minded a
cardiologist by the name of dr. Stephen
Sinatra a lot of your your your viewers
that he may be familiar with that name
if they're if they if they are are into
natural medicine or you know checking
out doctors that they'd offer a more
holistic approach to building health
than what is found in the in the
conventional mainstream but dr. Sinatra
in dr. Mercola we're talking about
different practices that can be good for
circulatory health and I found it very
enjoyable to hear dr. Sinatra actually
seemed to be most enthusiastic to
recommend the the act of grounding
yourself by walking on wet sand along a
lakeshore or an ocean shore and what
that means practically speaking is that
everything in our body runs
electrochemically everything in our body
runs electrochemically especially in the
brain and the nervous system and we can
actually experience a buildup of excess
electrical activity induced by stress
stress induced electrical excess
electrical activity in our biology can
be discharged though by simply putting
your bare feet on on wet sand along the
lakeshore and ocean shore you could even
just take some sand and throw some water
on it that may work as well we do
usually you know what we do we actually
put our for our fortify on the ground
get affray 5 times a day
yeah yeah but you know you want to
actually do that of course ideally right
directly on the earth were or because
you want to actually come and touch your
you want to make touch with make contact
with the earth so you give your body a
chance that's not what you're back in
today when we didn't have the carpets
and all juries right people were
actually getting more in contact with
the earth yeah so so in and the the best
place to do this is away from where
there's likely to be any electrical
power lines you know that's why doing it
along the lakeshore and ocean shore is
the most reliable way to do it but you
know you may be able to ground yourself
very well and a really nice grassy area
or even you know just a nice area of
dirt but it's it's it's something that
is very much taken for granted about
actually having a physical connection
with the earth this is actually very
valuable for helping your body to
discharge a stress-induced excess
electrical activity in fact there was a
practitioner at the optimal wellness
center Jeff Meisner who gave a lot of
attention to this in his and his work
with with the patients who came there
and so yeah that's that's that's part of
what I call fresh air you know having
appreciation for you know connecting
with with nature in a variety of
different ways that lifestyle those
lifestyle adjustments and thank you very
much thank you for being with us Jim
tell us if people would like to get a
hold of you to learn more is there a
website or number or well I am currently
not seeking any new people to do
nutrition and health education with but
there is someone who's actually been on
the Dean show who has trained with me
who is like one of your students yes yes
yes miss Michelle Gillespie and I've
given out her contact information on a
previous interview but you could on the
on the web page when you post this the
show which could put Michelle
Gillespie's contact information again
for people who are looking for get her
website up there yes yes yeah for people
who are looking for some specific
guidance I think she would be especially
valuable too for helping women in and
and their children yeah and you know
helping people to better understand how
to how to how to really get the best
quality real food in their daily meal
plan thank you Jim thank you Jim Marlo
thank you for being with us here always
a pleasure okay thank you so much thanks
you